we begin with the trial everyone tonight
is talking about and it is now official
the circus is finally over at least for
now a northern virginia jury has awarded
johnny depp 15 million dollars in his
definition suit against ex-wife amber
heard now the same jury then awarded her
two million dollars in her countersuit
against johnny depp in other words debt
netted 13 million dollars cleared his
name of the quote me too accusations
leveled by herd in a 2018 washington
post op-ed but in a civil case that
involved the wildest of allegations and
drug use and jealousy physical
psychological abuse verbal abuse and one
well rather unusual claim surrounding
human feces in a bed neither celebrity i
can tell you this emerged unscathed it's
like to watch binge watch one of those
netflix series uh it's dark it's all
consuming no real winners from the civil
trial for example here's one small look
into this couple's tumultuous
relationship very i did not punch you i
i did not punch you i did not deck you
i'm
hitting you i don't know what the motion
of my actual hand was but you're fine i
did not hurt you i did not punch you i
was hitting you how are you how what am
i supposed to do
now it would appear from what we just
saw that amber heard was the abuse of
one in the relationship here's one more
example of that alleged abuse take a
look
she threw the large
and it
made contact
and shattered
everywhere
and
i honestly didn't i didn't feel the pain
at first at all i felt no pain
whatsoever
what i felt was
um
i felt heat
i felt heat and i felt
as if something were dripping down my
hand you know
and then i
looked down and
realized that the
the tip of my finger
had been
severed
and
i was
looking directly at
my bones
and here is more testimony from dev
claiming that he would run from room to
room in order to get away from amber
heard which made her well let's say a
little unhappy take a listen
i think that i ended up blocking myself
in about
at least at least nine
bedrooms bathrooms
that day
um
as she was banging on the doors and
screaming obscenities and
wanting to
have a physical altercation
now keep in mind during the trial heard
also leveled some very graphic
allegations against johnny depp by the
way viewer warning what you're about to
hear is pretty disturbing take a look um
and and then it became clear to me he
was like looking for something he
um
cleared things off the bed
i went into the bathroom
and as i come out he's at he asked me
where it is
and how long i've been hiding it
i was like what are you talking about
and he says you know what i'm talking
about you know what i'm talking about be
honest with me
where are you hiding it and
he starts
you know
what it feels like patting me down or
saying he's patting me down i can't
recall but
he ripped my dress
the strap top part of my dress
he's like grabbing my
my breasts he's touching my thighs
and he rips my underwear off
and
then he
proceeds to do a cavity search
he was looking he said he was looking
for his drugs his cocaine his coke
now ultimately a jury did not find most
of herds outlandish claims to be
credible even after these text messages
from johnny depp to a friend listen to
this
i'd like to apologize to the court and
to the jury for some of the language
that i'm going to have to use today but
unfortunately
you're going to see a lot of documents
with language like this
after you said let's drown her before we
burn her mr death you said i will her
burnt corpse afterwards to make sure she
is dead
that's what you said now needless to say
regardless of who you believe or what
you believe uh one thing is obvious this
was not a healthy relationship in any
way especially given the allegations of
revenge defecation watch this
i had received some news
that was
as
absurd
and grotesque
and
cruel
um
and then i was shown a picture
of what the problem was
what was the photograph of mr depp
it was a it was a
it was a photograph of the bed our bed
um
and on
my side of the bed
um
was human fecal matter
um
so i understood why
it wasn't a good time to go down there
there are so many takeaways you can get
from this trial i guess you can start
don't do these kind of drugs it's not
going to end well
and also
again as a public we're reminded never
rush to judgment we do believe in the
presumption of innocence
due process is critically important
always and just because somebody does
make an allegation does not make it true
we saw this with justice kavanaugh we
saw it with clarence thomas we saw it in
the uva rape case we saw it with duke
lacrosse we saw it with nicholas sandman
cambridge police ferguson
missouri baltimore richard jewell and
and here we go again so many people did
rush to judgment in a statement from his
spokesperson depp celebrated the verdict
thanking the jury for giving him his
life back after the quote false and very
serious and criminal allegations that
were levied at him via the media
meanwhile amber heard now down 13
million dollars was less upbeat quote
the disappointment that i feel today is
beyond words i'm heartbroken that the
mountain of evidence still was not high
enough to stand up to the disproportion
of power influence and sway of my
ex-husband she continued quote i'm sad i
lost this case but i'm sadder still that
i seem to have lost a right that i
thought i had as an american to speak
freely and openly of course no one has
the right to defame someone in the
washington post even if the post is more
than happy to publish it hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else